today's episode is brought to you by
curiosity stream curiosity stream is a
subscription streaming service that
offers thousands of documentaries and
non-fiction titles for some of the
world's best filmmakers including
exclusive Originals it's available on
many platforms web app Roku Android Xbox
One Smart TV iOS Chromecast Amazon Fire
Amazon Kindle and Apple TV also
available worldwide now you may have
noticed that we've got a playlist here
on biographics that walks you through
the annals of American presidential
history now that's something you like
curiositystream has presidents in crisis
it's a great series check it out and if
that sounds interesting go to
curiositystream.com biographics for
unlimited access the world's top
documentaries and non-fiction Series
right now you guys can use the promo
code biographics to save 25 off the cost
of an annual subscription which makes it
only
14.99 a year which is an absurdly good
deal again curiositystream.com
biographics to save 25 right now and now
today's video
foreign
Bell Lord of Heaven and Earth committed
the rule of mankind Marduk when they
pronounced the lofty name of Babylon
when they made it famous among the
quarters of the world and in its
mid-established neverlasting kingdom
whose foundations were firm as Heaven
and Earth at the time Anu and Bell
called me Hammurabi the exalted Prince
to cause Justice to Prevail in the land
to destroy the wicked and the evil to
prevent the strong from oppressing the
weak and to lighten the land and to
further the welfare of the people
Hammurabi Am I who brought about plenty
and abundance those Eternal words serve
as the prologue to the Code of Hammurabi
an ancient legal text that marks one of
the first known attempts to govern a
society through the rule of law this
might represent Hammurabi's lasting
Legacy but let's not forget that he took
a minor city state that was completely
surrounded by bigger kingdoms and turned
it into one of the most powerful empires
in ancient history
Hammurabi was born sometime during the
end of the 19th century BC and the
amarite dynasty that ruled over Babylon
his exact birth year is unknown but it
is placed around 1810 BC because he was
a young man when he became king in 1792.
his father was the king of Babylon sin
mobileitz while his mother's identity
was unknown nowadays we might remember
Babylon as one of the main powers in
Mesopotamia but it was Hammurabi who set
it on this course at that time there
wasn't a single Empire powerful enough
to claim hegemony over the region the
last one to do so was the third dynasty
of uh okay the neo-sumerian Empire but
they had been destroyed by the combined
forces of the alamites and the amorites
about 200 years earlier since then
nobody had been able to Crown themselves
the Undisputed heavyweight champion of
Mesopotamia so the region consisted of
countless city-states that sometimes
port and sometimes fractionized with
each other in the middle of this
political brouhaha where the amorites a
group of 11 teen Semitic people who
migrated and occupied large parts of
southern Mesopotamia however they were
not United it under a single ruler
instead preferring to establish multiple
unrelated dynasties each centered around
a city-state that is what happened in
Babylon when the amorites took over
Babylon was just a tiny village on the
banks of the Euphrates but it steadily
grew over the course of two centuries
and by the time Hammurabi came into the
picture it had become a moderately sized
Kingdom that incorporated some of the
neighboring cities such as quiche and
borsippa we don't know much about what
his father Sin mobile did during his
Reign but we do know that the king
managed to repel an attack from lhasa
one of the biggest Sumerian neighbors
then his health started to fail him so
he abdicated Circa 1792 BC and Hammurabi
became the new king of Babylon as he
took the throne abarabi couldn't help
but notice that his kingdom was
surrounded by threats on all sides there
was still latter to the South-East ruled
by King Rim sin who had already tried to
invade once and would undoubtedly try
again when the time is right to the West
and Northwest there were the kingdoms of
Mari and ashnuno who weren't exactly
mortal enemy enemies of Babylon but both
had their desires to expand their
territories which meant they couldn't be
trusted but the biggest danger was posed
by The elamites Who ruled over a large
Kingdom to the east although they were
the most powerful entity in the region
they were naturally isolated from the
Rest by the Tigris River and the zagras
mountains therefore instead of trying to
permanently conquer neighboring land the
elements preferred to demand tribute
influence Royal successions and lead the
occasional raid just to remind everybody
whose boss with all these threats
looming Hammurabi knew that conflict was
inevitable not that it was against it
per se since he had his own Ambitions of
Conquest but he thought it wise to get
his own house in order before knocking
next door he actually spent the first
two and a half Decades of his Reign
avoiding any major conflicts while
undertaking new projects in Babylon such
as building temples and higher City
walls in case anyone got any ideas he
canceled debts which was standard
practice at the time whenever a new king
took the throne he constructed Bridges
across the Euphrates so that his City
could expand focused on agriculture by
building granaries and irrigation canals
to make the lands more fertile all of
this hard work paid off and in just a
few decades Hammurabi transformed
Babylon from just another minor
city-state into one of the key players
in the region the Babylonian King also
searched for allies in the area since he
knew that he could not take everyone at
once he found one in shamshi adad the
first a powerful King based in Assyria
who ruled over most of upper Mesopotamia
although shamshi a dad was also
interested in expansion he was busy
feuding with the kingdoms of Maori and
ashnana which were situated between his
domain and Babylon so he and tamarabi
had no reason to be whole star towards
one another but yet at least for now
Hammurabi had a different enemy to
contend with
[Music]
Hammurabi's burspo was also his
strongest alarm the two sides actually
started off as allies but as you soon
find out alliances during this time
weren't worth the tablets that they were
chiseled on the trigger over their
conflict was the death of the
aforementioned King shamshi a dard Circa
1776 BC which had a series of
repercussions in the region as his
former Empire splintered in the years
that followed during his Reign shamshi
Haddad had managed to bring Mari under
his Rule and installed his son on the
throne however the sun didn't have the
same juice to keep power without his
father's help so he was overthrown by
the previous Amorite Dynasty which
installed zimri Lim as the new king of
Mari at the same time the kingdom of
eschenuna took advantage of the chaos in
the region and gained ground fast
following the death of shamshi adard by
capturing many cities and expanding its
domain it was the re-emergence of
eschnuna as the regional power that did
not sit well with alarm because the two
kingdoms shared a large border and were
not on friendly terms of one another
therefore the alamide king siwi polar
kupak began courting other local leaders
just to gauge how fond they were of
ashnana fortunately for him the answer
was not very fond at all Mari and
ashnano were hostile towards each other
so King zimmery Lim of Mari entered an
alliance with ilam not wanting to miss
out on the fun Hammurabi did as well and
the trio declared war on ishna the
Coalition proved to be too much to
handle for ish no no which was conquered
and became part of the elami Kingdom the
annexation was somewhat unexpected
because up until that point alarm seemed
uninterested in expanding into the
Mesopotamian Plains preferring instead
to exert its influence indirectly
everyone was expecting sui balar to
plunder a few cities tear down a few
walls install a friendly puppet King and
then bugger off back to alarm this time
was different though as it was becoming
increasingly clear that Tsui palar had
grander Ambitions in minds of assuming
control over the entire region not only
did he conquer but the alamite king then
demanded to Hammurabi that he
surrendered the cities that Babylon had
occupied during the war furthermore he
then announced his intention
babylon's old Foe and requested more
troops from Hammurabi to Aid him but sui
pallor gambled on a risky strategy as he
sent a similar message to King rimlin of
Lhasa asking for his help in conquering
Babylon he did not pull off his
deception as both Hammurabi and rimson
realized that the alamite ruler had no
intention of stopping at just one of
their kingdoms or any other oh would be
sitting right there right for the
plucking sui Pilar wanted to play the
two warring nations against each other
but he accomplished the exact opposite
he United them against him even more bad
news for alarm was on the way because
King zimri Lim of Mari was getting fed
up with them as well initially he stayed
loyal but sewi Palace hubris made him
confident that he could do anything he
wanted in the region and get away with
it some of his armies attacked
settlements that were loyal to Mari and
under their protection and King zimmri
Lim was angered by sweet ballars and
differenced towards their actions
therefore when Hammurabi reached out
with an offer of an alliance to take on
alarm he accepted and started raising an
Army alarm made the first move laying
Siege to the city of UPI or one of the
settlements The Babylon had taken from
ishna it was a victory for the alamites
as Hammurabi could not send
reinforcements in time but the good
times didn't last long afterwards they
Advanced on hiratum which was bigger and
a much more important city on the
northern border of Babylon this time
though the elements had to contend not
only with a sizable Babylonian Force but
also with the Marriott reinforcements
and that was not all because the people
of ishananda did not want to live under
the element yoke they rebelled and drove
the alamite Army from the lands electing
one of their own as the new ruler a
commoner named silicon all of a sudden
the alamite forces found themselves
trapped between a rock and a hard place
the Babylonians at the front and the
rebel Army of a Schnitz at the back with
little Choice the now humbled sweeper
law sued for peace with Hammurabi and
retreated with his tail tucked between
his legs back to alarm and the safety
afforded by the zagras mountains it was
a glorious victory for Hammurabi as his
own steel proudly proclaimed with help
of the great Gods Hammurabi had defeated
the armies of alarm which had Arisen
against him as a great mass and he
established the foundations of Suma and
a card but let's be honest if the
reality was a bit different than how
Hammurabi chose to remember it it was
his good fortune that the elamide king
had managed to piss off everyone else in
the region before launching his invasion
if sui Pilar would have attacked from
the outset directly from alarm chances
were good that Babylon would have been
conquered and barely remembered as a
minor city state that was once part of a
larger Kingdom but as things stood
Babylon had repelled the elamite attack
and Hammurabi was now the one feeling
cocky and he wanted to go on the
offensive foreign
was no longer a concern sure losing one
battle wasn't exactly total Annihilation
but it did convince the elements to
revert back to their old ways of
tributes and influence instead of direct
Conquest therefore Hammurabi turned his
attention to the next biggest threat La
sir he and King rimson might not have
fallen for alarm strategy to play them
against each other but this hardly made
them BFFs in fact rimson refused to send
any troops to Babylon when alarm invaded
despite making promises that the two
nations would fight side by side
therefore immediately after repelling
alarm Hammurabi turned his army around
and marched into loss to settle their
old rivalry once and for all he was
still assisted by the Marriott Army and
the two forces made pretty short work of
their enemy they quickly captured
several settlements on their way to the
city of Latter where King rinzin awaited
over the bulk of his forces the city did
not fall after a pitched battle but
rather after a prolonged siege that
lasted as long as six months before the
people inside ran out of food at that
point the gates were opened and the
armies made Hammurabi came flooding in
officially bringing the kingdom of Lhasa
under Babylonian control as for Remsen
himself he was captured and taken
prisoner he died soon after which wasn't
terribly surprising since he was an old
man but the records don't make it clear
if he died of natural causes or was
executed by Hammurabi as far as lhasa
was concerned Hammurabi did not raise it
although he did tear down its walls he
did not want to Simply plunder the
kingdom he wanted to add it to his own
so he played the benevolent ruler card
he canceled debts he constructed new
temples and he resided in the local
Palace all the surviving inscriptions
made it sound like Hammurabi simply
succeeded rims in as the new King
instead of conquering and overthrowing
him with this Victory Hammurabi now
ruled over all of southern Mesopotamia
but this was not nearly enough so the
Babylonian King turned his sights toward
the north eschner was the next stop on
the Hammurabi Conquest tour technically
speaking the two nations were allies
Hammurabi even married one of his
daughters to Sila sin the new king of
ashnan to help cement this new Union but
he would not let such a minor detail get
in the way of his vision of a United
Mesopotamia under the rule of Mighty
Babylon as far as Hammurabi was
concerned alliances were ephemeral here
today gone tomorrow in fact the
Babylonian ruler also put the kingdom of
Mari on his Hit List he probably would
not have conquered Larsa or even pushed
back the alamite assault without their
help but Hammurabi adopted the well what
have you done for me lately Mantra when
it came to determining the value of an
alliance but before we judge Hammurabi
too harshly it seems that his
counterpart from eschner was busy with
his own Shenanigans and was just as
eager to double cross Babylon cilicin
had been in contact with various other
kingdoms big and small trying to
persuade them to break their treaties
with Babylon and not send Hammurabi any
troops he also convinced a group of
people that we haven't mentioned so far
the Guardians to conduct raids into
lhasa most likely an attempt to make the
territory rebel against Hammurabi's
control and last but not least ashuna
bribed alarm with a giant shipment of
grain to stay out of whatever was going
to happen so it's pretty clear that
cilicin saw the conflict was inevitable
but whether he did all of this as a
defensive strategy to try and limit
harabi's power or he intended to strike
a Babylon himself his mystery in fact
most of the details surrounding the war
are a mystery all we know is that
Hammurabi defeated King silicon and his
allies thanks to an inscription that
said he overthrew in battle the army of
ashnana sabatu and gutian the land
became part of the ever-growing
Babylonian Empire although it did Rebel
later during Hammurabi's 38th regnal
year and as punishment was destroyed by
a great plot whether this was a
metaphorical flood of death disease and
destruction a literal flood caused by
divine intervention or even an
artificial flood caused by diverting the
cause of rivers and canals to inundate
the city of eschner on purpose we just
don't know what we do know is that
Hammurabi had no intention of stopping
there
with a schnitter out of the way
Hammurabi turned his attention to
Northern Mesopotamia as we previously
mentioned this region used to be all
under the rule of one king named shamshi
adart but once he shuffled off his
mortal coil the sons were not strong
enough to keep his domain together so it
splintered into many small kingdoms and
city-states these proved to be no match
for the power of Babylon and today many
of them are only remembered as names on
tablet inscriptions listing off
Hammurabi's conquests some of them
willingly became vassals While others
were forcefully integrated into the
Babylonian State once this was done only
one real Target remained the kingdom of
Mari in the past Hammurabi and King
zimri Lim had been close allies fighting
together against ishnuna ilam and lhasa
in fact almost all the military
information we just presented came from
the marry oats and they were much more
diligent record Keepers than the
Babylonians and King zimri Lim and King
zimmri Lim received detailed reports on
all of Hammurabi's comings and goings
this might be because zimrulin had
realized a while back that there would
come an unavoidable time or when the two
last Regional Powers would Clash to
determine one king to rule them all and
spoiler alert that King was Hammurabi
the lands of Maori were too rich fertile
and strategically valuable for someone
like him to Simply let them go
unfortunately while we know the outcome
of this war we are completely in the
dark about the specifics the Marriotts
were the ones who wrote down everything
that Hammurabi was doing and on this
particular occasion they didn't need to
write it down since they saw it
firsthand what we do know is that
Hammurabi assembled two armies on the
borders of Mari and tried to act all
innocent by claiming that they were
headed to a different Kingdom called
akalitum but nobody was buying it even
with his foolproof deception exposed
Hammurabi didn't find it too difficult
to conquer Mari the Mario historical
record disappears suddenly just four
months after the Babylonian conquest of
ashnana which indicates that the
Takeover occurred pretty swiftly zimmery
Lim completely vanishes from the records
at this time so his fate is unknown a
similar mystery surrounds the city of
Maori itself evidence suggests that
Hammurabi raised it and turned it to
Rubble but that this did not happen
immediately instead the Babylonian King
took this drastic step a few years later
when the Mario oats tried to Rebel if
true this is consistent with the fate of
eschner suggesting that Hammurabi had a
strict one strike and you're out policy
when it came to cities that tried to
escape his hegemony anyway after being
raised Bari still lived on as a minor
settlement but it never again reached
the same Heights as before
with this last Conquest Hammurabi's
vision of the first Babylonian Empire
had finally come to fruition it was in
his 33rd regnal year that Hammurabi
returned to Babylon as ruler over most
of Mesopotamia proclaiming himself King
of the amorites and the king who made
the four quarters of the earth obedient
strictly speaking the earliest Sumerian
Empire was little big as a Hammurabi
didn't quite manage to assemble the
largest Empire that the world had ever
seen but his feet were still remarkable
especially Owen you took into account
just how inconsequential Babylon was
when he first took power what's perhaps
even more impressive was that Hammurabi
managed to maintain his Empire which is
often times the hardest part ruling over
a large territory that consists of
multiple cultures and Languages by most
accounts it was a good ruler one
preoccupied with improving the lives of
his subjects remember that all the
warring and conquests only lasted for
about four years out of a 40-plus year
reign the rest of the time Hammurabi
spent building all sorts of construction
projects beautifying cities fortifying
walls improving food production and of
course revolutionizing legal history yes
only now have we reached Hammurabi's
True Legacy that of a law Giver empires
have come and gone since his time many
of them much larger than Babylon but the
Code of Hammurabi still lives on in a
place of pride inside the Louvre Museum
as a seven-foot pillar made out of black
basalts as well as multiple copies
located inside the U.S Capitol the
headquarters of the United Nations and
other prominent places put simply the
Code of Hammurabi is an ancient legal
text that is often hailed as the oldest
known law code in the world but that's
not actually correct that distinction
belongs to the Sumerian text called the
code of uanamu but Hammer Abi's code is
certainly the most detailed most famous
and best preserved legal texts that we
have from that time while the code of UR
namu for example only has five legible
laws the Code of Hammurabi has 282 rules
and statues that showed that Hammurabi
was a king whose ideal Society was one
built on Law and Order applicable to
everyone although not necessarily in
equal measure so what do you want should
we start with the good the bad the ugly
okay here's the good first the Code of
Hammurabi had some revolutionary
Concepts that are still found in law
codes today it was one of the first
examples of innocent until proven guilty
it included benefits for marginalized
groups such as widows and orphans and
even provided a form of alimony payments
it established a minimum wage for
certain workers such as doctors
Shepherds and field laborers and gave
women the authority to conduct a
business and own property and even
pursue careers such as scribes the bad
stuff has to do with the punishments for
breaking the law which were exceedingly
harsh more often than not someone would
be getting their hands chopped off or
being thrown into the Euphrates River
Hammurabi was a firm believer in the eye
for an eye approached Justice even when
it involved innocent people if for
example a house collapsed and killed the
son of the homeowner then the son of the
Builder would also be put to death as
punishment even though he had nothing to
do with it so if you were a kid in
Babylon you'd better pray to mardok that
your father was good at his job the ugly
which let's be honest is just the bad
stuff under a different name is that
punishments were not dispensed equally
as they varied based on social status
and gender the husband could have a
mistress but not the wife if a nobleman
hit another nobleman he would be flogged
in public if however he had a commoner
that was just fine if doctor killed a
man then off with his hands if the
victim was a slave however then the
doctor just had to replace him and he
got on with his day so obviously the
code was far from perfect but it's
almost 4 000 years old so some
allowances should be made Hammurabi's
Empire slowly started crumbling
following his death Circa 1750 BC but
his law code ensured a long-lasting
place in history for him as one of the
world's Premier lawmakers
foreign
[Music]